en las últimas 72 horas el salvador ha
registrado más de 40 homicidios una
cifra que supera con creces el promedio
de 3 asesinatos diarios sostenido hasta
inicios de noviembre las autoridades han
atribuido esta oleada de asesinatos a
las pandillas que operan en el país lo
que pone en entredicho la efectividad
del plan gubernamental orientado a
controlar el accionar delictivo de estos
grupos el gobierno ha reaccionado con
operativos militares y policiales de
gran escala y anunció nuevas acciones
para contener la racha de violencia y
devolver la tranquilidad a los
salvadoreños esto en medio de un
ambiente de zozobra y preocupación entre
la población que también es testigo de
un alza en las desapariciones con un
registro de un poco más de mil denuncias
de personas desaparecidas entre enero y
octubre del 2021 según cifras oficiales